[Music]
hello everybody hello hello thanks for
coming
my name is Corey O'Connor and I'm
product manager on Android TV for major
platform features including the system
UX setup and more hi I'm Isaac Etta
Nelson and I'm the technical lead for
the home screen and launcher experience
so I know happy hours coming up and
we'll try to keep this really
interesting to the point and get you two
drinks shortly after
I'm going to start and give you all an
ecosystem update and walk through some
of our new announcements and then I'm to
hand it over to Isaac and he's going to
give you the technical details about how
you as Android developers can bring the
new experiences to your apps so there
are big changes coming to Android TV but
before we dive into them we wanted to
take a little bit look back this year
in short it's been a great year for
Android TV we continue to see amazing
growth in the number of devices our
strong partnerships with pay TV
operators and hardware manufacturers
have allowed us to more than double the
number of devices that have activated in
2016 and we actually expect that to
continue if not increase in 2017 and
going forwards we're seeing this growth
both in the set-top box form factor
which includes streaming devices and
cable and satellite form factor boxes
and in addition to the Smart TV form
factor since last year at i/o we've
launched a number of new devices with
partners including the dish air TV with
DISH the me box which down me and with
Airtel we actually launched the first
satellite set-top box based on Android
TV in India this year so that's pretty
exciting the list of partners up here is
actually just a few that we wanted to
call down we've also expanded our
international footprint to 70 countries
and there are now more than 3000 apps on
the Play Store so that's pretty pretty
exciting Android TV apps in addition
though mobile viewing has grown the TV
still dominates for Leanback content
there's a recent Netflix report came out
shows that while acquisition of a user
can happen across the number of form
factors that could be laptops computers
phones tablets and the TV itself
sixty-seven percent of long-term viewing
happens on the TV and in the living room
now this just validates what we've
long-held which is the TV app experience
is critical for content providers it's
what you have to nail in order to down
deliver long term highly satisfied users
as dave said in the keynote this morning
Android TV has seen tremendous growth I
think his stats were a million new
activations every two months but as they
say the best is yet to come so we
launched Android TV three years ago and
since then we've learned a lot but this
year we took the opportunity to take a
step back and take stock of where we
were on the platform and also how
changes to how people were engaging with
content in the living rooms now across
the industry we found these three common
issues these three core needs that were
really going on addressed so the first
thing we saw was it it's really hard to
come to grips with all the different
content available to us so families now
have multiple sources for what they want
to watch depending on the mood the time
of day who's in the room and a bunch of
other factors and it's interesting
because content is mostly visible within
the app or service so what you do is you
turn on the TV and you have to actually
like deep dive into the app to see it
has if it has something you're you're
actually interested in watching so it's
become really hard to know what's
available before you figure out who you
want to watch it from which we kind of
realize is a bit of a weird situation
also the problem gets a bit harder
because there are so many different
types of content available to watch it
could be video on-demand and that could
be through subscription paid or rented
it could be digital web driven sort of
social content or it could be live
television through a pay TV subscription
or an antenna or over-the-air source so
as of yet it's been really hard to fold
all of these different types of content
into an empowering experience
for users so the second thing we saw is
that the emotional hook from a piece of
content that we see it's diminishing you
can imagine that we may have found our
way into a list of options that could be
recommendations or something like that
and we're seeing the movie yard or
poster art and we're just we're not
feeling connected to any of it
now with this a huge number of options
for content available to us which we
which we love we like a big menu but
we're losing our ability to make a
decision now we saw users with these
huge lists of options available to them
maybe there's a watch list that they've
curated or maybe there's recommendations
that they've made sure you know as much
as possible that they reflect what they
want to watch but when the time comes to
actually play something off event they
really can't find the spark that they
originally had why they put it there in
the first place so the watch list had
become more aspirational than actionable
the third thing we saw people were
really looking for ways to tweak the
content on a device to customize it for
how they want to watch so when you bring
a TV to your home and you sign up for a
service or an app the shows the actors
that they become part of your family
they're part of your routine you watch
them every night if it's like a ritual
we think that part of this should be
being able to nest with the device to
customize the experience so that it fits
with your life and your needs if you
watch people get a new TV or a new phone
one of the first things they do is they
sort of move things around right you
move the apps around you set the
background you set your ringtone you
customize it to how you want to use the
device but with TV from a Content
perspective people really can't do that
now these concerns have been around for
some time we're not surfacing these is
the only people to have ever discovered
these things but they come out now and
again in user research and market and
analyst reports they're known known
issues but what we've done is we've
taken these issues to heart in Android
oh and we've set out to directly address
them with a major refresh of Android TV
now the first major change you you
probably have already heard about
earlier this year we announced the goo
assistant will be coming to Android TV
the Google assistants is your own
personal Google you can ask a questions
you can tell it to do things it's always
ready to help and it's available across
all your devices so you can integrate it
into your life
now what does that really mean for TV
well what are the core design principles
in bringing the assistant to the TV was
it people are trained from a young age
to to talk about media with others to
use our voice in the discussion about
what we want to watch or what we feel I
do this frequently with friends and
family we go back and forth about what
we're interested in figure out if it's a
show or a movie how much time we have
left what's available to us and we
arrive at a decision this sort of
interaction feels very natural it's what
we're used to when we're dealing with
people in everyday life now we think
that voice is an amazing augmentation
for media consumption in the living room
so what we've done is we've optimized
the assistant on TV from the ground up
to fill this role that means within
Android TV you can use the remote alone
to navigate the UI you can use the voice
button on the remote and you'll be able
to talk to the assistant or you can use
the assistant in a hands-free mode to
discover and play content even better
you can transition between these modes
seamlessly so whatever you want to do it
fits the situation you're in if you want
to talk it's there if not no big deal
now there was a bunch of work that went
into us getting here we had to build
multiple speech models UI that's
responsive to the situation in context
of a user and a number of other things
but what it's resulted in is a new more
natural and transparent way of
interacting with your TV in addition
because it's the same assistant that
connects your Google and third-party
services and devices you can use it in a
bunch of interesting scenarios so
actually let's take a look at one of
these let's imagine it's Friday night
and I'd like to watch a movie I might
say show me some Risha in action movies
now the Google assistant knows it's me
and it knows the context where I'm at
and what sorts of things I'm interested
in like actors for example so it's going
to bring up a list of things that might
interest me from from multiple sources
there might be a way to further refine
the search or broaden it but let's
assume for now that I see what I'm
looking for one thing to note is the
assistant can work in a conversational
manner meaning that it's going to
remember the contexts I have in case
there's a follow of request so I think I
see something I'm interested in in in
this case I want to watch Deadpool which
which is a hilarious movie by the way
but if for example it's a complicated
title or if I'm feeling a bit lazy I
might just refer to it by the order it
is in the list like I might be talking
to someone else in the room so I might
say play the third one now what's
happened is the assistant understands
where we're at in the conversation and
what I'm trying to do and so it's going
to play the content that I requested
from the source that I that I had now
maybe the movie is just starting and the
families sitting down ready to watch and
we realize we want to make the
experience a little bit more comfortable
so because it's the assistant it's
connected to the other devices in my
house and I can control the lighting in
my living room just by asking so I might
say dim the lights the lights dim and
we're ready to watch the movie now the
second major change they say home is
where the heart is so in order to truly
change the way people use Android TV we
had to make a change to our home for
Android oh we've redefined this home
screen on Android TV to be a channel
based content first experience this new
home enables users to engage with the
content and apps that they love all in
the same place now instead of you
showing showing you more screenshots up
here we decided at a bit of risk to
ourselves to actually give you a live
demo using a developer device that we
have and we'll walk through the features
on that so could we switch to the Nexus
player please
Isaac's going to help me out for this so
I wanted to call out that we're still
putting the finishing touches on this
experience so you should expect to see
further visual changes and performance
improvements as we moved closer to
launch so let's walk through the layout
a bit so at the top you're going to see
the same quick access to search that
you're used to and below that we're
introducing a favorites row for favorite
apps to easily launching the favor
right from the top of the screen you'll
see watch next below that and we'll come
back to favorite apps and watch next a
little bit later in the middle and
continuing down we have a number of rows
full of content that we call perhaps
unsurprisingly channels so a row is a
channel these channels are the core of
the new home screen experience each of
these channels is created by a media app
to display content relevant to you you
might think of each channel as a window
into the content available inside the
app now apps surface content in channels
by displaying programs which are the
boxes you see here with TV shows or
movies or video on them so we got a
channel inside a bunch of boxes those
are called programs these are
recommendations for content that's
available right now for you to watch and
they could be on-demand content like a
movie a TV series could be a video clip
live TV show could even be a live
traditional TV channel and actually
there's a couple more Isak we'll talk
about that later
now each app gets to decide what the
channels named what it looks like what
content appears in it what metadata goes
with that content and in what order the
content is displayed in that channel
when you select a program that seems
interesting to you it's going to launch
the app and take you directly into the
content starting playback immediately if
you decide to press the back button from
there the app has the ability to sort of
reengage you and takes you to a higher
level screen inside the app now by
structuring the experience this way what
we're allowing apps to do is surface
different types of content in the same
experience giving you the choice of what
you're in the mood for now you could see
in the same experience what's on your
DVR what movies are recommended for you
to rent and what on-demand shows maybe
you haven't finished binge watching yet
in addition apps have a lot of control
about how they want to present what they
think mode is most relevant to you so
there's a good balance there
all right actually let's go to the Play
Movies channel and let's select
fantastic beasts
I thought I shine in white ice and it's
those down on the ground now what you're
seeing right now is the feature we're
really excited about called video
preview from our research we found that
seeing short previews of the content has
a significant boost to engagement and
decision-making and that kind of makes
sense so let's use fantastic beast as an
example
I know it's set in the Harry Potter
universe and I love the Harry Potter
universe and I've seen it come across my
recommendations often I haven't yet you
know pull the trigger but when I focus
on it in this discovery experience and
it plays the preview I see the world and
I see the characters and I hear the
music and you know it's no longer a post
and poster to me I'm drawn in now apps
have the ability to provide video
previews for each program they put in
the channel regardless of what type of
content that might be that might take
the form of a live preview for con for
live content it might be a trailer for a
movie for a TV show it could be the
series trailer or it could be we like a
season trailer and for video or digital
social content it might be maybe the
first 15 seconds of of what what that
content is we think this is going to
drive a lot of engagement for our app
partners and we're seeing many
developers integrating already and you
can see it's quite a compelling
experience as we're in the discovery
mode here over a poster so maybe I'm not
in the mood for a fantastic piece right
now let's actually go to the next one
and take a look at hidden figures
so you can see how powerful these video
clips are where we're sort of previewing
the content that we may want to watch
right from the Discovery experience it's
almost like I'm in the movie theater and
I'm watching the previews I mean getting
excited about what I'm about to watch
now what happened when I was actually
this looks great
so let's let's open it up and launch it
what are you waiting to burn after
caffeinate your trajectory now what
happened is we clicked on it and it
launched directly into the Play Movies
app and it's playing the context this
experience works really well you can
tell with the existing app model so
we've hopped into the middle of the
movie let's pretend for a moment that
watch has to show but I have to stop and
let's go back out to the home screen and
let's go back to the top please so what
you're seeing is that the content has
been added to my watch next row because
I wasn't done with it yet in the system
is helpfully saying look you have this
available still to watch the watch next
row is a single system deliver channel
that's always at the top where content
you previously engaged in will be
presented and this will be from all apps
watch next is designed to give you an
easy way to get back to content that you
know and love especially it's something
your binge watching or actively
recording or you haven't finished in
addition if you haven't watched
something yet but you want to in the
future you can add it to the watch next
note row directly so I did get excited
about fantastic beasts I think it was
the preview video so let's go back to
play remove ease row let's add it to
watch next and let's go back up to the
top
you can see now how the watch next row
over time is going to reflect the things
that I like to watch so an app is not
just restricted from offering only a
single channel in fact it's just the
first channel from every app that
appears automatically apps can actually
offer multiple channels for user to the
home screen which basically gives the
app more real estate for them to sort of
draw the user in with their content you
know I wonder if YouTube actually has an
extra channel YouTube has lots of
content available so let's go take a
look we're going to go to customize
channels and we're gonna go to YouTube
will do it questions in a little bit so
so we're seeing multiple channels here
you know today at the keynote I think
Sara mentioned that the YouTube is
launching 360 videos on the TV and
Android TV was going to be one of the
first devices to get that well for a
demo surprise surprise what a complete
coincidence we have a channel with 360
videos so let's enable that are as you
can see the channel was added to the
home screen so actually let's check out
one of these videos I think we're on a
Coachella video so let's open that
launch the YouTube app now Isaac's going
to use the remote to look around and I
think this video is pretty cool it's got
actually multiple 360 cameras all
throughout the audience and on stage I
think we're going to do transitions
between these different cameras so you
can kind of look around and see what it
would be like to be on stage in the
audience backstage a whole bunch of
things so this this video is pretty
great let's hop back out but make sure
to go and check this out on your android
TV
I think it's launching in the next few
weeks so the ability to have multiple
channels from the same app and channels
from different apps allows you to have
content for everyone in your family's
case available from the same UI so we've
seen how as a user you can go and
proactively look for channels available
to you through apps that are already
installed on the device also though when
you're in an app that app can suggest
channels to add to the home screen so
dialogue would appear and you would say
yes or no and if you said yes that new
channel would appear
in this way as a developer if a user is
is interacting with some specific part
some team part or something relevant for
you to create a channel you can actually
proactively suggest hey there's there's
something you can add to your home
screen from my app would you like to do
that the last thing we wanted to mention
is that there's still a way to access
all the apps on the device whether
that's because you're launching an app
that doesn't fit really well into the
media first model or because you're just
more comfortable clicking on icons and
brands and that sort of thing resonates
with you so from here you can also set
which apps appear in the favor throw we
talked earlier so let's go ahead and add
YouTube kids to the favorites row
because we have friends come and stay
with us and it would really help to have
an app that is very easy for them to
launch is very visible for content
available for them so it was added up
there so could we change back to the
slide please
so in addition to the home screen we've
made changes all around the Android TV
platform and we really don't have the
time to discuss them in this session but
I just wanted to pick out two examples
so it's part of Android Oh we've built a
completely new set of experience for the
TV that's going to help you transition
media apps from other Android TV devices
to your new TV during set up if you for
example have an Android phone with TV
relevant apps on it and you're signed in
to a Google account when you're doing
setup on your TV we're going to suggest
installation of these apps with a simple
click of a button we're going to install
the app in the background and that app
will then proactively put channels full
of content on your home screen so that
by the time you're done with setup
voila you're going to land on the home
screen and it's going to be full of
channels full of content available to
you and even better if that app
integrates with smart lock what we're
going to do is we're going to remember
the login information so when you click
on this app or click on a piece of
content it's going to automatically sign
you in so you'll get out of your out of
the setup flow your TV will have content
you click on a piece of content you go
right into watching it also we've made
updates to components in the Leanback
library and call this one out this is a
great update to the playback elements
that adds detailed seek thumbnails it
looks amazing and it's actually
extremely useful when you're trying to
find
something specific in the speak in the
in the seek so we talked a little bit
about the three challenges we saw on the
living room when it comes to
entertainment and we also talked about
the changes coming to Android TV now
with the assistant we're menteng the
remote to have natural voice
interactions with your TV and we're
really excited about the new content
first home experience on the Android TV
we think you're going to find that it's
easier to figure out what to watch it's
more fun to look at your available list
of options and it's more engaging when
you actually customize this experience
for what you're what you're looking for
now the assistant will be available on
Android TV devices back to marshmallow
and it'll be later this year and the new
home experience will be launching on all
Android TV devices when they upgrade to
o so expect to see the first devices
with this new experience late this
summer now I'm going to hand it over to
Isaac like I talked about before and
he's going to talk about the technical
details for how you as Android
developers can help us create this
experience with your apps Thank You
Corey
[Applause]
so let's talk specifics what can you
they are developer due to showcase your
content your app context on the home
screen we start with the basics we are
using two well-known Android concepts
the first one is the content provider we
use content providers with new API for
storing Channel and programs data your
app should insert channel and program
data into the providers and the system
will automatically show it the other
concept is we use intents to tell your
app when to insert your first channel
and when your user is interacting with
your content you will use a broadcast
receiver to listen to this intent and
act upon them and of course to make it
easier we provide a support library for
easier implementation but what exactly
do you need to do what should the app do
and exactly when so to better understand
it I'm introducing Shay Isaac jaeseok
a brand new fictional Android TV Android
TV app the app allows you to watch
cooking videos and even categories
favorite them rate them and create
personal content channels and I will
show you what I did in my app to
showcase my content on the home screen
so let's begin the first thing I added
to my app is a broadcast receiver to
listen to this intent they initialize
programming 10 they intend insane is
sent to your app to my app once the app
is installed so very basically a
broadcast receiver to listen to the
initial program in 10 once the receiver
is called I start a job I use a job
scheduler or you can use firebase job
dispatcher too doesn't really matter and
I insert to insert my channels so I
decided to insert three channels two or
three channels is about the right number
of channels I can fine-tune it later
when I know my users taste better so as
you can see the I schedule using a job
scheduler a task if you notice the zero
on the set minimal latency with me when
you set it to zero it means that they
the system will actually schedule this
job immediately which is a good thing
because we need the channel to be
visible immediately after the app is
installed the job runs a simple task
that actually pulls data of my channels
for my back-end and insert them into the
provider but how do you do that so how
do you insert the channels so we have in
the support library several builders to
help you build channels and programs to
insert them into the provider so I use
the support library channel builder to
create a channel and you can see I setup
the type to preview I set the display
name to the channel name and I set a
link back to my app so when the user
click on the channel icon it actually
opens my app and I use the content
resolver to call insert and just insert
the data into the provider and the last
thing to do is actually add a logo to my
channel so there's a call for that and
actually you can either provide a bitmap
or if it's too hard then after you can
provide a URL to the bitmap somewhere on
the Internet and supported we will
download it for you and actually insert
it for you same thing for programs for
each channel I will use a builder to
insert the programs so I set the channel
ID the same one that I created before I
set the type for me it's clip I set the
title the description there's way more
metadata to insert I'll talk about this
a bit later and then I insert the URI
that will actually when clicking will
play the content will call my app to
play the content and again I use the
content resolver to insert it into the
provider and the last thing I need to do
is ask the system to make the channel
visible and to do that I do one simple
call I request it to be visible
browsable and presto that's it I created
my first channel I want to take a moment
to talk about the first channel what the
app is installed it gets what we call a
golden ticket the ticket which the app
can use to insert the channel without
the user approving rather user
interaction will be visible by default
they app gets one golden ticket so once
you insert the first channel this ticket
is gone and cannot be used anymore
so if you want to add additional
channels it needs to be approved by the
user so the first thing you need to do
is do not
of your first channel your default
channel use it updated but don't remove
it
since my apps shows video clip I will
use the program type called clip but
there are many other program types to
use and it depends on the content that
you're showing what types to use and
each type has a different metadata
associated with it the API
documentations online show very well
what exactly the metadata you need for
each clip type for each program type so
just to show we have seven type of video
programs for movies to TV season and
live channels and you can understand
that if I use a TV episode I may have
the episode number and the season number
which is not be relevant to a movie so
we'll use different metadata for
different kind of programs the same
thing for audio we have five types of
audio programs talking about a made
metadata each app has a title it has a
description it has more metadata like
the release date the length of the
program a user rating
there's author there is price there's
many more fields available and of course
we have it for the most the visual part
of it which is the most important part
you can insert two different images oops
one is when the actually images focus
your program is focused on the home UI
and one when it's not focused and of
course you can also use the preview
video which there has the most visual
effect the more metadata you add the
better so
my app is installed on the device user
used it watch a few videos even edit a
second channel using the customize
channel and it's great but I want the
user to be engaged more I want the user
to watch go go back to my app and watch
more content so how do I do that to do
that I need to keep my content fresh to
update my channels all the time so what
I did I used cloud messaging to have my
back-end ping back to my app when new
content is available when my up gets
this ping this message I run a job again
I run job in the background to pull this
new content for my back-end server and
also to query the data that's actually
on the device in the provider so I know
what new and what's already on device
and I'm going to sync kind of
consolidate the two data sets when I do
that I try to do what I call it smart
things so I will compare the two data
sets and then I will remove all programs
that are not not available anymore
I will add new ones that are new and the
ones that are still there I can update
them maybe the release date change maybe
the number view change I can do that
update the programs and also maybe
change the order because some of them
are more popular than others and that's
okay
we try to avoid the remove all add all
concept or paradigm because what happens
if you do the smart thing
the visual will be better though the
less visual glitches will which is
movement onto your channel and that's
what we were aiming for so I have more
channels I have them with fresh new data
what's next so either the feature into
my app to actually allow the user to add
channels from the app itself so when the
users are interested in topic or the
category I pop up a view which has a
button it to and suggest the user to add
a button to add the channel to the
screen home screen when there is a click
on it what I need to do is a few simple
things first of all again I need to
build a channel to insert so I use the
program builder to insert the channels
and the programs into the provider and
then I do one more thing is ask this
to make it visible and the way it works
is that I create an intent which called
channel browsable request channel
browsable then I do
startactivityforresult they spell the
system to actually show a confirmation
screen and remember golden ticket is
gone you need the user approval the user
can approve or not and when the user
approve it or not I can actually know
what the user replied by checking on
activity result and I know if the user
actually approve it or not and do it
what I want blue three challenge now on
the home screen good job so let's move
on
so another opportunity to engage the
user is actually the watch next channel
remember that was the channel that was
on top of the screen and it's a system
channel so you don't have to create it
but you do need to follow some
guidelines in order to use it so the
first thing I did I added support in my
app to actually monitor what's added to
my watch next channel so every time a
program is added to the watching sense
that it's my program I want to know
about it and I want to track this so
it's a very simple API you can add
remove and check if the program is in
the watch next channel and you can
implement it with a database or should
press pretty easy thing to do so let's
look at some use cases so let's talk
about the continue playing so the user
watch one of my videos but didn't finish
watching it so what do I do what I need
to do is actually add a program like
before the same concept I set the type
the clip I did another type which is
what kind of type it's on the watch next
channel this time is continue watching
what we call continue here and then I
had three more data to it one is when
did it happen and the other two to help
us with the UI is to the length of the
program and the current play position
and again simply again just insert it
into the provider and you're done and if
there is a keep on playing the content I
can just update the current play
position to update the UI great I have
another card on the watch next channel
one more thing I can do is that if I
have some click that are part of that
season or series when the user is led to
watching the states watching episode 2 I
can insert episode 3 and say that's the
next one to watch or maybe if I've at
the end of the season M and then X is
and I can add a card for the next season
a program for the next season so what I
did is actually edit again a program by
same type type clip watch next is next
the type is next like next item and just
adding when I inserted it in so it will
be in the system
oops and again I have another card on
the watch next channel the last thing my
app does is actually listened to the
watch snare added to watch next as you
remember the demo we long press on the
program click the add to watch next and
it was added to the watch next what
happened is that the pro system actually
takes the program from the from the apps
channel and copy it over to the watch
next channel we do that so that the
visual effect will be immediate but what
we also do is we send an intent to my
app to tell it
this program was copied and edited watch
next and what I did in my app is again
putting a receiver to listen to this
intense and the next thing I do is start
a job and I save this information inside
my own database so when this program is
updated maybe the number of you change I
get a refresh of the image I can
actually also update it in the watch
next channel so the content will be
fresh
ok so let's recap
what should an Android a TV app do so
first of all it needs to add channel
right after install at least one keep
the channels up-to-date refreshed engage
the user the app can suggest more
channels inside the app use the watch
next channel to engage you to continue
watching the content and listen and
direct user interactions and of course
do not remove your first channel thank
you for coming and listening if you'd
like to learn more we have sandbox area
we're going to see the demo again we
have code labs you can actually go in
and build your own TV app and you can
come to the office hours I'll be there
and you can ask questions or you can go
online and see the documentations thank
you so much for coming
[Applause]
[Music]